schockmoment an bord von flug united
airlines 328 von denver nach honolulu
das rechte triebwerk ist stark
beschädigt und brennt an bord 231
passagiere und zehn besatzungsmitglieder
der vorfall ereignet sich kurz nach dem
start des flugzeugs vom typ boeing 777
zahlreiche maschinen teile fallen auf
bewohnte gebiete rund um die
nachbarschaft von broomfield colorado
über verletzte personen ist nichts
bekannt
auch von der polizei veröffentlichten
fotos sieht man flugzeugteile im
vorgarten eines hauses liegen andere
teile stürzten auf einen sportplatz auch
die überwachungskamera eines
kinderspielplatzes zeichnet auf wie
teile vom himmel fallen
augenzeugen berichten von einer
schwarzen qualmwolke die maschine konnte
trotz des triebwerksschadens wieder
sicher auf dem airport in den ball an
was macht denn eigentlich ein pilot wenn
auf einmal die termiten brennt zuerst
wird er versuchen die turbine
abzuschalten die und die
treibstoffzufuhr zu kappen damit kein
weiteres cuisine und triebwerk rein
läuft und die macht die triebwerke habe
man sich auch noch feuerlöschanlagen an
bord mit denen die brände in erster
linie meist gelöscht werden können und
dann geht es natürlich schnellstmöglich
zurück zum nächsten flughafen
jetzt bin ich kein experte aber wenn ich
da raus gucke und sehe eine brennende
turbine dann frage ich mich wie kann das
flugzeug noch weiter fliegen mit nur
einer
also erstmal ein triebwerksausfall ist
noch kein grund dafür dass ein flugzeug
vom himmel runterfällt dann ist die
frage wenn ein triebwerk ausfällt wie
viele triebwerk hat das flugzeug
überhaupt die 747 die in maastricht
gestartet ist hat vier triebwerke dort
ist das linke ausgefallen bedeutet das
hat noch 75% triebwerksleistung mit den
verbleibenden drei anderen triebwerken
bei der triple seven von you're dead
airlines über demba ist eins von zwei
triebwerken ausgefallen heißt es 54
prozent leistung auch das ist aber noch
kein problem auch mit einem triebwerk
kann jede maschine jede zweimotorige
maschine noch je nach maschinentyp bis
zu 300 330 minuten fliegen
und kann dementsprechend sicher landen
eine maschine könnte auch bei einem
triebwerksausfall auf der startbahn im
staat vorgang wenn dann ein triebwerk
ausfällt könnte die maschinen trotzdem
noch mit einem triebwerk sogar starten
eine platzrunde drehen eventuell triebe
treibstoff ablassen und dann sicher
wieder landen und eine andere frage wenn
das brennt denkt man natürlich auch
gleich oh gott hoffentlich sind die
tanks jetzt nicht in der nähe dass das
ding hochgeht wie ist das denn da bei
einem flugzeug ja das ist natürlich
feuer ist immer das gefährlichste an
bord sei es am triebwerk sei es in der
kabine sei es in der otto riehm toilette
man kann halt nicht rechts ran fahren
und sagen wir löschen das ganze jetzt in
dem fall wenn jetzt das triebwerk
abgeschaltet ist oder es brennt nur noch
und der die tragfläche ist nicht
beschädigt dann ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
herunter kommt sehr sehr sehr sehr groß
weil natürlich kerosin in den tanks ist
kerosin in den tanks kerosin zum bauch
kerosin und hinten am seitenleitwerk so
was ist immer immer gefährlich aber
solange der tank nicht beschädigt wird
und die treibstoffzufuhr unterbrochen
ist ist eine sehr große
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die maschine
auch heil wieder landet das trainieren
die piloten auch was schief gehen kann
hat man 2000 gesehen als bei der
concorde in paris ein teil eines reifens
die tragfläche durchbohrt hat da hat
sich der tank entzündet und die concorde
explodiert
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren